here we
are Envision the new world the solar
Punk future complete harmony with Earth
complete harmony with each other basic
needs met for all children frolicking
with excitement and freedom women and
men in Harmony in
Divinity abundant and
free technology being in complete Unison
and harmony with nature and with
humanity and you can hear those birds
chirping you can feel the the animals
that are around
also in play with the
humans the
Flora also the planets green ecosystems
coming alive with excitement instead of
being
choked and you can see how from that
place we can be abundant in our space
exploration
also we can become exactly what God has
destined us to
be we can have complete abundance and
prosperity for
all it's already done it's there you're
there you're envisioning it
now this
Galactic this
Universal this free energy
this abundance for all this complete
creative freedom complete harmony with
nature complete saturation into love and
Divinity
constantly it's already there you're
already
there now constitutionalize as that and
never
move and that's how the new world
manifests